the Georgia grand jury that evaluated
the possible case against Donald Trump
and Associates that has finished its
work is recommending indictments we are
now waiting to see who gets indicted
unfortunately one of the things that may
be jeopardizing those indictments is
that the four person of that grand jury
Emily cores did a bizarre media tour
appearing on at minimum MSNBC and CNN
seeming at times giddy at other times
koi at all points cringe-worthy I got to
swear everybody in and so I thought it'd
be really cool to get 60 seconds with
President Trump and aside from the
inappropriateness of what she has been
doing there's a question now are the
indictments that were recommended going
to stick or is something about that
bizarre media tour going to interfere we
can only wait and see it wasn't looking
very good for Donald Trump but without a
doubt this giving new ammunition to
Trump and his lawyers will watch it